[Music]
did you ever think about how many
balloons it would actually take to make
a house float did you notice which real
person the villain was named after maybe
you did if you watched the movie as a
grown-up keep watching for more stuff
and up kids don't normally
catch up begins by introducing carl and
ellie two youngsters who bond over their
shared love of adventure yet before they
even meet we see a nine-year-old carl in
a dimly lit movie theater screening a
black and white newsreel wide-eyed and
filled with wonder young carl's gaze is
glued to the screen as a crackling 1930s
voice-over tells the story of famous
adventurer and carl's hero charles muntz
the newsreel describes the rise and fall
of the fearless explorer which later
comes into play in the third act of the
movie because the main plot of up takes
place in 2009 it's possible that its
core demographic might not be aware of
the historical reference being made at
the beginning of the film today movies
and theaters are preceded by ads behind
the scenes sneak peeks trivia quizzes
trailers and so on in the early days of
cinema however short documentaries
covering the events of the day were the
norm of course once televisions became
available in most households theatrical
newsreels went the way of the dinosaur
it's likely that most kids and honestly
even many adults might be a bit out of
the loop on this one
kids are often under the impression that
adults have an endless supply of cash
they're the ones with the jobs after all
they buy the food the clothes the toys
the tablets so why do they always claim
that they don't have any money when the
kids ask for it they must be a bunch of
liars right up provides a very good
reason why this is not the case in the
movie's montage opening ellie and carl
can be seen dropping coins into a jar
labeled paradise falls their dream
vacation destination of course they
often must break the jar open to dig
into their savings because well stuff
happens flat tires hospital visits and
roof repairs are just a few examples of
unpredictable expenses that grown-ups
have to contend with sadly these trials
often mean that dreams and future goals
have to be put on hold if they even
happen at all as the old saying goes
life is what happens while you're making
other plans most adults know that those
plans and life tend to cost a lot yet as
up also teaches life's greatest
adventures can also be had without ever
spending a dime
when most fans think of up they think
about the film's first heartbreaking 10
minutes in that short period we see a
lifetime of memories flash before our
eyes what makes the scene even more
moving is that it happens mostly without
dialogue using simple and relatable
imagery to tug at the audience's
emotions you know you don't talk very
much
i like you
it's probably safe to assume that for
most young people the montage is just
there to provide a backstory for carl
sure there's some sadness to it but it
may be difficult for some younger
viewers to understand why their parents
are reaching for the tissues and one
moment of the sequence in particular
might go a little over the heads of most
kids while ellie's death is certainly
poignant for many adults it's the scene
of her miscarriage that gets the tears
flowing lots of kids may have had to ask
the adult in the room to even understand
what was happening losing a child before
they're born is a painful ordeal one
that only those who have experienced it
for themselves can never know ellie and
carl's heartbreak is evident but it's
one that kids will have to grow up a
little more to truly fathom
shortly after the audience sees carl in
his natural state they are introduced to
aspiring senior wilderness explorer
russell he's a rambunctious
eight-year-old who is trying to earn his
assist the elderly badge and has his
eyes set on assisting carl unfortunately
for russell carl has no need of
assistance and no patience for the
well-meaning boy to get russell out of
his hair carl asks for his help in
tracking down a snipe that has been
getting into his prized azaleas russell
eagerly accepts the task only to later
learn the whole thing was a ruse though
the imaginary snipe hunt may be a new
concept for kids some adults may find it
all too familiar in fact it's a
tradition going back generations fans of
the animated series king of the hill may
remember another reference to snipe
hunting from the season 1 episode the
order of the straight arrow in which the
practical joke goes a bit too far for
russell and carl and up however the
snipe becomes a wondrous aspect of their
journey i found the snipe oh
did you
an early scene and up shows carl
relaxing in front of a glowing tv set
before his respite is interrupted by
russell knocking on the front door the
audience doesn't have to see the screen
to know what carl is watching even a few
seconds of audio is enough to recognize
a home shopping segment yet only adults
if they are paying close enough
attention may recognize the clip's audio
from a famous viral video of the 2000s
the particular clip that carl is
watching is a home shopping blooper
video in which a man is promoting the
sale of a high-quality camera to
demonstrate the camera's printer
capabilities he holds a giant blown-up
photo of a moth he then states very
confidently that the photo is a picture
of a horse saying look at that horse
the bushy tail the big t
the hooves
it's only when the producer relays the
truth to him over an earpiece that the
host realizes his mistake but by then
the damage has been done and the
hilarious result was ripe for internet
fodder
one thing that pixar and disney do well
is feed audiences imaginations in unique
and awe-inspiring ways that's certainly
the case with up when carl's beloved
home is lifted aloft by an array of
colorful balloons and start soaring
through the air viewers know that they
are in for the ride of their lives
[Music]
as majestic as the site is however many
adults can't help but feel a stab of
cynicism at the concept according to
slate magazine pete docter the
co-director of up said that the number
of balloons estimated by their
technician team to carry out such a feat
is 23.5 million however animating that
many balloons would have been far too
daunting a task so pixar settled for
just over 20 000 in the scene where the
house first lifts off and half that
number in subsequent scenes since then
many have attempted to answer the
question of how carl's floating balloon
house could actually work one video from
youtuber matthew patrick delved deep
considering every potential factor from
the house's building materials to the
ratio of helium and mass weight in the
end patrick estimated that it would take
approximately 31 million balloons to
achieve the stunt in real life
the antagonist of up is the washed-up
explorer charles muntz who has made it
his life's work to find a rare species
of large bird evidence of which he was
once accused of fabricating and clear
his good name when he discovers that
carl and russell are in the company of
the female bird they've named kevin
montz's greedy obsession turns to
thoughts of murder months will do
whatever it takes to claim his prize
even if it means he has to kill an old
man and a small child to do it munz is
clearly a bad guy but what younger fans
might miss is that the man whom he is
named for was something of a disney
villain himself in walt disney's early
days as an animator his distributor was
a man named charles mintz mintz had a
hand in commissioning disney's first
popular cartoon character oswald the
lucky rabbit but mintz ultimately
cheated disney out of the ownership of
oswald and stole most of the disney
brothers animation team forming his own
studio which would later become screen
gems unfortunately for mints oswald the
lucky rabbit isn't well remembered today
disney soon created another character
whose popularity would make his company
the world's most powerful media empire
the walt disney company also purchased
the rights to oswald in 2006.
some jokes never get old and a bunch of
dogs playing poker is one of those
timeless classics during the climax of
up russell and carl's bird friend kevin
is captured by the dastardly charles
muns when carl refuses to help russell
fearlessly takes on the mission by
himself mounting a leaf blower held
aloft by a bouquet of balloons against
all odds russell makes it to montz's
giant zeppelin the spirit of adventure
with carl close behind after a change of
heart as russell approaches the spirit
of adventure he is spotted by monsters
guard dogs through the window the pack
is in the middle of a card game with one
bulldog in particular seeming to have
won the jackpot of doggie trees this is
of course a funny visual gag but kids
probably didn't get the cultural
reference it's a nod to a famous series
of american paintings dogs playing poker
by cassius marcellus coolidge coolidge
created 18 paintings for his iconic
series the most recognizable being a
friend in need which was painted in 1903
the artwork depicts seven dogs of
various breeds sitting around a poker
table and holding cards one of them even
has an ace of clubs hidden away just
like one of the dogs in up
marvel movie and credits are known for
their sneak peeks and easter eggs but
disney and pixar also have their little
secrets as well watch the end of up and
you'll see a few at the beginning of the
movie carl collects his mail and finds a
brochure for shady oaks retirement home
he scoffs at the literature clearly not
even considering assisted living to be
an option however he is forced to leave
his home after attacking a construction
worker and presumably losing a court
battle two retirement home employees
show up at his door to escort him to his
destination but he manages to escape
their clutches after carl and russell
return home from their adventures
audiences can get a glimpse of a few of
their outings via scrapbook photos in
the end credits they can be seen
picnicking on a hill visiting a museum
and chasing after a squirrel hunting dug
there is also a photo of the two of them
with the elderly folks at what is likely
shady oaks the dogs from muns's crew
enjoy quality time with the residents
and it appears that carl also feels
quite at home with his own house now
overlooking paradise falls it looks as
though carl may have decided that
assisted living wasn't such a bad idea
after all
from the film's opening scene to the
role of the end credits the theme of up
is abundantly clear adventure is out
there and despite what kids might think
life doesn't end when you're old for
carl his first adventure began when he
met ellie in the abandoned house in his
neighborhood that adventure continued
when he and ellie wed though it came to
a sad end at her death however as carl
soon learned his own adventures were far
from over instead of accepting a quiet
and mundane life in his twilight years
he decided to seize the day and go on
his very own journey of discovery and
wonder just like carl as a young boy
everyone at one time in their lives has
felt the need for adventure whether it's
playing pretend in their backyard or
seeing the world and just because people
get older doesn't mean they lose that
spark and lust for life as carl learns
throughout his time in up adventure is
indeed out there and can be found in
many places marriage is an adventure
life is an adventure and you're never
too old to hold on to that childlike awe
and go out and seek it for yourself
early
is so beautiful
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you